Gentlemen!
In your chairs,
brothers and sisters.
Now, I propose that we
devote the closing prayer
to a faithful
member of our flock
who is leaving us
tonight, to fill
a position of great
importance in foreign parts.
I refer to our
brother, Brutus Jones.
Will you bow your
heads in prayer?
Almighty everlasting God, we
the people of Hezekiah Baptist
Church is gathered
together for the purpose
of giving into your keeping
our brother, Brutus Jones.
Like the prodigal son in
the story, he's-a setting
out on a far journey.
But this boy ain't
like the prodigal son.
He ain't shiftless,
and he ain't worthless.
Oh, Lord, he ain't puffed up.
And he ain't vainglorious, Lord.
Mm mm, honey.
You sure is wonderful
in them clothes.
Yeah.
I suppose these
clothes is something
to look at back here, honey.
Where I been while I've
been training for the job,
you would notice 'em.
Well, you ought to see them
New York girls on Lenox Avenue.
Them gals is fast, I bet.
Switching theirselves
to catch the men.
But honey, you wouldn't
look at none of them
fast gals whiles you away
from home, would you?
They ain't none of 'em as pretty
in the face like mine gal.
And that prodigal son, he takes
the inheritance for
his pappy gives him,
and he spend it
on the fast life.
But not this boy, Lord.
No, Jesus, not this boy.
And the prodigal son is a liar,
and the truth ain't in him!
But not this boy, Lord.
He got the truth, Lord!
You know I looks up, and there's
the Capitol building, looking
like a palace on the hill.
And the big front door opens,
and the President of the United
States marches down the
avenue with a band before
and a band behind.
And he comes right up to my car,
and he says, just as natural,
"Well, Brutus, you
sure is much of a man.
And I, for one,
wants to compliment
you on landing a job."
Honey, they're singing the
closing song at the church.
We's got time.
Jeff's train's going to pick
me up at the water tank.
But you know they's waiting
to see you before you go.
I sure hate to leave my gal.
Would you hold my hat, honey?
Hello, Suzanna.
Hello, Brutus.
- Hello, brother.
- How you doing?
Fine, thank you.
There's your train, son.
Goodbye, folks.
Goodbye, brother.
Take care of yourself.
Goodbye!
Goodbye, Mama.
Goodbye,
Here she is.
Come on, Jones.
Here's my buddy.
Honey, this is Jeff.
Hello, sister.
Make tracks, bo, cause
we's riding right now.
Come on. - All right.
But this is too much!
You is coming back, ain't you?
Oh, sure I's coming back.
You just get yourself a
new dress with this, honey.
You know, a red one.
That's your style.
And take care of yourself
until I come back, now.
Come on!
All right, old boy.
It's all right, honey.
Take care of yourself.
Don't worry.
I'll be back very soon.
Take care of yourself.
Goodbye, honey!
Goodbye
Bye bye, honey!
Bye bye!
Shine 'em, boy.
You done told 'em goodbye now.
You going to stick to it?
Sure, I is.
Cause you big time from this on.
Now, I suppose
you think you know
all there is about this job.
Sure, didn't you
done instruct me?
Oh, just the rudimentary.
Now we's going to take
up the higher education.
Finances.
Yes, brother.
And right here's
where I estimates
the profits for the run.
Now, if you brushes a dime
out of this, you's doing well.
And number three here, boy,
that's good for a half.
What about this one?
Number five.
A whole section.
That's a honeymoon couple.
That's a natural.
If you plays your hand right,
it means the long green.
Big money, eh?
That's what I want
to tell you about.
You know, there's two kind of
women that rides the Pullman.
There's the kind that says,
"Where you been, Porter?"
That don't mean
nothing but a tip.
Then there's the
kind that sings out,
"Hello there, Jack Johnson!"
And boy, that means money.
The long green.
Yeah.
And I'm going to show
you where to spend it.
Everybody, meet my friend
from South Carolina.
Helen, meet Mr. Jones.
Jones, meet Mr. Green.
Gee, that's very strong.
Come here, Marcella.
Meet Mr. Jones.
This is Marcella, Jones.
Hello, big boy.
I got your fish and
rice all ready for ya.
You know, I'm from
South Carolina, myself.
You told me you
was from Georgia.
Told me Lynchburg.
Marcella sure had a busy ma.
She done born her in every
state south of the line.
This is my New York home, bo,
and you'll always find me here.
Oh, Marcella, where's Undine?
I don't know.
She was around here somewhere.
Didn't know I was coming in, eh?
Honeying up to my gal, eh?
Take it easy.
Don't do that.
Don't do that, son.
Not inside of my house.
You ain't gonna send me to jail.
Uh uh.
Y'all go ahead and dance!
There she is.
Undine, meet Mr. Jones.
Pleased to meet you, Mr. Jones.
Wanna dance?
Sure.
Go ahead.
You're my buddy, ain't ya?
How you like the city, big boy?
I like it fine now.
Coming back soon?
Soon as the train'll bring me.
I'll be here.
Honey, I sure glad to see you.
I get to missing you more and
more during these long runs.
You know, you oughtn't ask
me to come here to meet you.
I been afraid.
Afraid a what?
Um, you know.
Jeff.
He's a bad actor over me.
Well, you ain't got
nothing to be afraid of.
I can handle that
little two-bits porter.
You oughta throw
him over, anyhow.
Then it'll be just you and me.
Sometimes I wonders.
Wonders what?
If we gonna last.
You ain't got nothing
to worry about, honey.
But you ain't heard
the good news yet.
I been transferred to the
president's private car.
Aw, that ain't nothin'.
Why, Jeff said you don't
make no tips on that job.
That's why he didn't take it.
There you are.
That's the difference
between me and Jeff.
He can't see no
bigger than two bits.
Me?
Why, I just be steppin' to my
own class on that private car.
Harrington, if
there is no leak,
we stand to clean up millions.
That's the idea.
Good night.
Good night, Jones.
Good night, sir.
Anything on your mind, Jones?
I's awful worried
about that merger.
Sure would be bad for
us if that news got out.
Us?
Hm.
How long have you
been with me, Jones?
Six weeks, sir.
Learning fast Jones.
Almost too fast.
Got any money, Jones?
I got about $300 in the bank.
All right.
You're in the pool for $300.
Thank you, sir.
And Jones, I would
rather you didn't
leave the car until Sunday.
Two days solitary.
But it'll be worth it, right?
Yes, sir.
And Jones, when we
get back to New York,
it might be a good idea for
you to go back on your old run.
There's more room for
big men in Georgia.
Yes, sir.
Boy, you sure was born
to wear that oyster front.
Where'd you get such a good fit?
Well, the boss
and me talk it over.
And he sent me to his tailor.
He said, Jones, you got a
position to live up to now.
And you can't afford to be
careless in your attire.
You and Mr. Harrington
must be getting mighty thick.
Well, we just pulled off
a little deal together.
I gave him some valuable advice.
And he said, Jones,
you're learning fast.
You're getting big.
Then he takes me
into partnership.
But ain't you going back
on the Pullman no more?
Oh, I'll stick by the
job for a few more runs.
But things don't seem
to be going quite
right on that old run of mine.
And the boss asked me
to drop down that way,
straighten them out.
Well, I guess since
you'll be down that way,
you'll probably drop
in the White House.
Well, that's an idea.
Look here, what are
you trying to do?
Kid me? - Me?
Kid you?
Boy, you're a scream.
"Jones.
You're gettin' big.
You're learnin' fast.
Then he takes me
into partnership."
Come clean, big boy.
Where'd you get that
money, in a crap game?
Go laugh some more.
You done laughed yourself
right off of my payroll.
Oh, honey, sweetheart,
I didn't mean it.
I was only kidding.
No, you's too
funny to live with.
Any woman's baggage what
gets heavier and heavier
the longer you totes 'em.
You got to change 'em
to keep traveling light.
Here's $40, and goodbye.
So you was all set to do
this before you come in, eh?
Through is through.
You heard me.
And you can go back to Jeff.
He still thinks there ain't
nobody like his Undine.
Yeah.
Well, you ain't the first
man that's gone down and out
thinking everybody was a fool.
I got eyes, even if Jeff ain't.
And you can tell that polecat
Belle La Due, if she wants
to keep on trying
to look like Garbo,
she better stay out of my way.
Slim, sister!
Well, if it ain't the old
big timer in from the West.
Hello, Jeff.
Hello, Undine.
Undine, meet Miss La Due.
I've known Belle since before
she straightened her hair
and when she went with Johnson.
Where is he now, Belle?
Still in jail?
Undine, where is your manners?
I'm just trying to
talk so that the polecat
can understand me.
Come on, baby.
Let's dance.
What's the matter with
you tonight, Undine.
Now, I don't like you
acting sore to my pal.
Your pal.
Yeah.
Don't make me laugh.
Why, he's been biting you
in the back for a year.
What do you mean?
I mean, when I get
finished with Belle,
he ain't gonna have
much left to love.
Oh, you dirty...
Hey you!
Stop that!
Come on.
I's travelling light.
Number
eight's his point.
Come on, you nits.
Get back and
give me room, will ya?
What's the matter, Jeff?
I never saw you in such a mood.
Never mind the lip.
Get these nits back
away from the table.
Hey, fellas, come on.
Back up.
Give him a chance.
We ain't in his way.
Shoot!
Hah!
On the line, you nits.
Eighter from Decatur.
Beaver dice.
Big dick.
Who is that singing?
Is that you, Lily pie?
Yes.
Well if you can't sing no
better than that, shut up.
Jeff's gal must've
sold him down.
Yes, what's eatin' you, Jeff?
You been trying to ride somebody
ever since you come in here.
Ah, woman, dry up.
Let 'em roll.
Gentleman says you've faded.
Push over, little tender.
Let a man have elbow room.
$20 they don't.
$20 to do.
Shake, rub, and roll
'em here, brother.
Hot dice.
Hah!
The man went away.
Here, Jones.
Give me a shooter
there, somebody.
Come on, give me a shooter.
15 cents I shoot.
Man, take that
chicken feed off of here
and play it on the line.
Come on, give me
a shooter there.
Big money talk.
What you shooting, Mr. Jones?
- Put in a nickel.
Put in a nickel, he goes!
I... I got the nickel.
You can't bet with
it in your hand.
Put it on the wood.
- Let him shoot.
Let him roll.
He's faded.
Hold my hat, nit.
Hah.
Great balls of fire.
Big dick.
Don't get nervous, boy.
You can back it.
Let me have it.
Six-four me, dice.
11.
Who wants any part
of these four sawbucks?
I makes my point.
Let the dice bring on misery.
Let him hear 'em chatter.
Six-four me, dice.
Six-ace.
The man went away.
You know, why don't
you get up off the table?
Can't you see your coat
sleeve's stopping my dice?
What are you talking about?
Can't I make a bet?
Here, old boy, you win a dime.
Here you are, Jeff.
Mark mine.
Who's the next shooter?
85 cents I shoot.
85 cents the lady shoots.
Bring your bet here.
Your cushions favor me.
Let 'em roll. She's faded.
Twenty the dice do.
Let the hussy sprain her wrist.
I'ma cut you a brand
new mouth with these dice
and give you something to put in
it, you long, black snake, you.
Eleven dice.
Snake eyes.
The lady goes.
Say, Stumpy, were
you on me then?
Yeah, I was.
Didn't I tell you
never to get on my bets?
Yeah, but honey,
this is a crap game.
On the line, you nits.
Catch 'em hopping and
let 'em hear 'em chatter.
- 20 and a nickel I shoot.
- 20 and a nickel he shoots.
I got a nickel.
Let 'em roll.
On the line, you small fish.
I'll take you too.
Let 'em roll.
$80 the dice do.
$160 they don't.
They do.
I knowed I'd have
a crap game today.
The Yankee boys is in town.
Let 'em roll.
The man's fading.
Catch 'em hoppin'.
Hah.
Eleven, natural.
What's the matter?
Put the dice down.
Crooked, huh?
Well, if they is crooked,
they stands just like him.
And here's where I
straighten them both...
Jeff!
Come here, Jones.
Open it up.
Asleep, eh?
Well, I'll learn
him how to run away.
Wake him up.
If I lay my hands on that boy,
the Lord will strike me dead.
Won't take orders, eh?
Dump it, old boy.
Let 'er go!
Dolly.
Let me in, quick.
Dolly, honey, you hear me?
Who dat?
Brutus, honey.
Let me in, quick.
Oh, Lord, I'm glad to see you.
Oh, but you's in trouble.
Listen, Dolly, you
got to move fast.
Get me a file, a change of
clothes, especially shoes.
But you's cut!
Hurry, honey.
I've got to leave the country.
Say, where is this
tub stopping next?
Kingston.
Get there tomorrow.
Ain't we stopping on these
little islands on the way?
Boy, this no local.
This running express.
Kingston.
Quite a big city, eh?
Now you're shouting.
They got everything.
Dancehalls, gals.
They got telegraph?
Cable, you mean, big boy?
Sure, they got cable.
What's that little
island with the white port
we've been coming
on this afternoon?
That's one of them there
little nigger islands.
But nobody bother go that place.
Ain't nothing there but trouble.
Trouble is my buddy.
Say, bo, watch my door.
I ain't gonna be long.
OK.
Trouble, here I come.
Who there?
Who that?
What you want, buddy?
All right, all right.
I'm coming.
Your Highness, Mr. Smithers
is waiting to see you.
Show the gentleman in.
Send Mr. Smithers in.
Well, your excellency,
the good has come.
And I brought you a few samples.
First class, just
like I said they'd be.
Now, here's the figures.
$400 cash for the lot.
Oh no, I got the
contract this time.
The contract, he said, $300.
Contract?
Well, that's just
the blooming point.
You see, uh, here it says,
"except for an act of God."
Now, then, there ain't the
like of that consignment
within 300 miles.
And the next boat don't
get here for two months.
Now, ain't that an act
of God, so help me?
Where you get that trash from?
On the beach.
Where you come from?
Come to make trouble on
my island, filthy swine.
Lock him up and throw him
on the first boat out.
I'll take this blooming
nigger off your hands
for you, your highness.
Here.
Here, five silver dollars for
him, lock, stock, and barrel.
What do you say, now?
Is it a trade?
Good.
Here, wait a minute.
Here.
Bring him here.
I want to have a talk with him.
That's all right,
he belongs to me.
So that's what it
is, my lad, eh?
What they calls in the
States a bad nigger, eh?
A killer, what?
With the law on your
trail and the blooming
gallows waiting for you
around the next corner, what?
Look here, white man.
I comes and I goes.
And that's my business.
Oh, that's the kind
of a nigger you are, eh?
Not afraid to stand
right up to your betters
and tell them what's what?
You wouldn't be afraid of a bit
of a fight, neither, would you?
When I fights,
there's something in it.
I never fight on an empty belly.
Yeah, well supposing
your belly was full
and you had a chance to
get back at the stinking
heathen what threw you out?
What would you say then?
No use talking, white man.
All right.
Now, you get your
rum and your eats.
But you don't get a stinking
penny, because I'm a trader,
see?
I ain't no bloomin' missionary.
And if anybody worries
you, you just tell them
you belong to Mr. Smithers.
I belongs to Mr. Smithers.
What's that?
Ginger.
Cocoa.
What's that?
- Ginger.
- Ginger?
What's that?
Coffee.
Coffee, ging...
Well, this ain't regular.
But maybe the dice will do.
Now, they goes first to the
gentleman with the Rolls Royce.
All right, talk to him, bo.
What I say?
Fever in the South.
Fever south.
Eighter from Decatur.
Eighter from cater.
Big dick.
- Big dick.
- Hah!
Hah.
Well, shoot, man.
Don't you know
"hah" means shoot?
Boy, the whole pile goes to the
gentleman with the Rolls Royce.
Well, all right.
Gather it in.
All yours, buddy.
I'll be dressed up
here in a minute.
I'm going after that hat.
And I'm rogue.
Natural.
Let me have it boy.
Now, Quacko, what do you say?
This whole pile to
get that Rolls Royce.
Hah.
The house is rolling.
Now, come on, you
galloping dominoes.
Come home to papa,
and let 'er ride.
Hah!
Nine is the gentleman's point.
Come on, eighter from Decatur.
Come on.
Hah!
Even us out, baby.
The gentleman made his point.
Ah, the team is mine, Quacko.
That's tough luck.
Better luck next Saturday night.
Me play woman for oxen.
Oh, no.
Women is women.
And Brutus Jones is through.
Well, I'll see you
boys next week.
Look 'em over.
So long, Quacko.
I'll see you later.
I wonder what the blazes
is keeping that black ape.
Whoa.
Boy.
Here, where do you
think you're going?
Oh, good morning, Mr. Smithers.
You works in here.
Well, to tell you the
truth, Mr. Smithers,
the boys back in the bush
seems to like my methods.
And I's figuring to
open up a little tradin'
business next door here.
Cut my bleedin'
throat, would you?
After all I've
done for you, too.
Is that your idea of gratitude?
Well, I's always ready
to listen to reason.
And while I'm unloading, if
I was to hear anybody say
something about a partnership...
Coconut, pineapple,
finefat chicken, all ready
for the tooth.
Raisins and new corn, coconut,
pineapple, great big chicken,
all ready for the tooth.
Pineapple, big chicken
ready for the tooth.
How do you do, Mr. Smithers?
How have you been?
I'm sure glad to see you.
How do you do?
Why don't you come in
and pay your bills?
You know, everytime I rides
up here through that jungle
it gives me the creeps.
Say, you notice they
shut the gates after us?
Looka here, white man,
is your nerve slippin'?
Well, I don't like it.
If you had to recruit
an army for him,
why did you have to
get such big blokes?
Yes, them is fine niggers.
I bet you they knows a
man when they sees one.
Well, if there's
any trouble, you've
only got yourself to blame.
Saluting him and calling
him General and...
Well, now I tell
you, Mr. Smithers.
If there's any trouble, you
just leave the General to me.
Us niggers understand
each other.
Tell him Mr. Smithers.
You know, you gotta
be diplomatic.
Take it easy.
Mr. Smithers to
see you, excellency.
Show the gentleman in.
Well, good day to
you, your majesty.
Well, well.
Top hole, eh?
Top hole.
As fine a body of men as
ever I clapped me peepers on.
Eh, what, Jones?
Right.
Yeah, and well farmed, if I says
it myself as fitted 'em out.
Eh?
What?
Well, General, you
got a swell army.
And I reckons when you figure
how little it's costing you,
makes you feel mighty proud.
Send in the treasurer.
This my treasurer.
Tell the General the truth now.
Does you know how to figure?
Yes, your highness.
Now, you see, I got a figure.
Produce the contract.
Your bill, Mr. Smithers.
Yeah, well, here you
are, your excellency.
Now, then, there was
100 uniforms at $5.
It's $1,000.
It was 100 rifles at $5, $1,000.
One cannon was $500.
And the ammuni... well, it adds
up to $4,000, your excellency.
What does the treasurer report?
It seems to me that there
might be a little error.
Uh, well, here... here,
let me look at it.
Yeah, we all make
mistakes now and again.
Yes, there is a mistake.
I seen it all along.
It's $5,000.
There you is, cap'n.
Check that off and
tell it to the boss.
Fire.
[LAUGHTER
Fire again.
Plenty of guns.
Don't you all knows
I's got a charm?
Takes a silver bullet
to kill Brutus Jones.
My turn now, General.
Company.
Attention!
Take this bush nigger and
throw him out of here.
I'm boss here now.
All of you, get out
of here and wait.
Them what I wants to stay
will hear from me in an hour.
Smithers, you wait.
I wants to confer with you.
Well, blimey if you
ain't pulled it off.
You have got a nerve.
Nerve and brain.
I calls it stinking
luck, having that nigger
miss you twice at 10 feet.
Pick up that gun.
Break it.
Blanks.
Blimey, how...
You remember when Quacko
got drunk in town last night
and I takes care of his
gun while he sleeps it off?
Well, that's what I call brains.
Whew.
This place smells more like a
chain gang dump than a palace.
Say, Smithers, how
you likes the contract
for doing this dump over?
Now you're talking.
And don't make the
mistake of thinking you're
dealing with an
ignorant bush nigger.
I gives you an
audience tomorrow.
Hey, and bring
along them fashion
sheets that I gets last summer.
And then I want mirrors.
Plenty of 'em.
And remember, Smithers,
red's my color.
I always had a
special taste for red.
Mr. President.
No.
King Brutus.
No, somehow that don't
make enough noise.
Smithers, cigarette.
Light.
Smithers, you have
just had an audience
with the Emperor Jones.
My sash.
Watch that foot.
Give me a drink.
My coat.
Brush it off.
Tell Smithers I'll
sees him here.
Clear out, all of you.
Your majesty.
Well, Smithers, what's
on your mind this morning?
Well, you remember what I
told you when you slapped that
last tax on coffee,
that you were cutting
your own bloomin' throat.
Sure, I remember.
What of it?
There was a riot down
in the village last night.
And your tax collector got
beaten up so his own mother
wouldn't know him.
That's old stuff.
My army's got them
niggers already.
And I'm going to get 'em
down before the whole court
this morning.
They all need a lesson.
Too late to give 'em
a lesson now, my lad.
You've got 'em squeezed dry.
Looka here.
When I take this job,
what I tells you?
I says, three years for
my cleanup, don't I?
Well, we's got six months to go.
Them's my arrangements.
And I ain't gonna change.
I suppose you get your
money hiddent away safe, eh?
I sure has.
And it's banked in a foreign
land where there ain't
no chain gangs and no
jim crow and nobody
can't get it except me.
In six months, I walks
out on this nigger circus.
And from then on, I's top dog.
Top dog, eh?
Looka here, white man.
There's little
stealing like you does,
and there's big
stealing like I does.
For little stealing, they get
you in jail sooner or later.
But a big stealing?
They makes you emperor
and puts you in a hall
of fame when you croaks.
Well, all I know is
that it's a wise gambler
that knows when to quit.
Looka here, white man.
You think I ain't still got
these niggers like that?
You think when I crack the
whip, they don't jump through?
All right, I shows you
I'll summon the court.
His majesty is on the throne.
Summon the court.
Archduke and
Duchess of Manhattan.
Marquis and
Marchioness of Newark.
Marquis and Marchioness
of Baton Rouge.
Lord and Lady of Baltimore.
Lord and Lady Richmond.
And all points in his
majesty's kingdom,
north, south, east, and west.
And Mr. Smithers.
Bring in the prisoners.
So yous the niggers
what takes upon yourself
to start a roughhouse and beat
up an officer of the crown?
Well, I see I been too
easy on you niggers.
Now I'm going to show you
who's boss around here.
Lieutenant.
Take them niggers
in the courtyard
and give 'em 50 lashes
a piece and lock 'em up.
I said lock 'em up!
Forward march.
Captain!
Take your company to
the five-mile village
and burn it off the
face of the Earth.
Everything!
Understand?
Right face.
Forward march!
March!
Who dare whistle
that way in my palace?
Who dare wake up the emperor?
I'll get the hides frayed off
some of you niggers, sure.
It was me whistled to you.
I got news for you.
Oh, it's you, Mr. Smithers.
What news you got to tell me?
Where's all your court?
The generals and the
cabinet ministers and all?
Oh, they mostly run the minute
I closes my eyes... drinking
rum, talking big down the town.
How come you don't know that?
Ain't you sousing with
'em most every day?
Well, I got you in
my business and I...
Your business.
Blimey, when you
landed here, you didn't
have no high and mighty airs.
Talk polite, white man.
Talk polite, do you hear me?
I'm boss here now.
Is you forgotten?
It's all right.
No harm meant, old sop.
Well, I accept your apology.
What I was then is one thing,
and what I is now is another.
I wasn't afraid to hire
you that time after you
broke jail in the States.
No, you didn't have no excuse
to look down on me for that.
You been in jail
yourself more 'n worse.
That's a lie!
Who told you that fairy story?
There's some things
I ain't got to be told.
I can see 'em in folks' eyes.
Well, from what I've been
told, it ain't safe for a black
to kill a white
man in the States.
You mean lynchings scare me?
Well, I'll tell you, Smithers.
Maybe I does kill one
white man back there.
Maybe I does.
And maybe I kills
another right here before
long if he don't look out.
Here, you think
I'd peach on you?
Not me.
I'm your friend, ain't I?
Sure you is.
And you'd better be.
And to show you
that I'm your friend,
I'll tell you that bit
of news I was going to.
Go ahead.
Shoot the breeze.
Must be mighty bad news
from the happy way you look.
Ain't noticed
any of the servants
or the guards around the
place this morning, I ain't.
Oh, they all out in the garden,
sleeping under the trees.
All I gotta do is to ring that
gong and they come flying.
All right.
Ring it now, and
you'll see what I mean.
Sure, I'll ring.
The rotten ship is sinking,
and the bloomin' rats
have slung their hooks.
Low-flung woods niggers.
Well, I reckon overplayed
my hand this once.
A man can't take the pot on
a bobtail flush all the time.
Was I saying I'd sit
in six months more?
Well, I's changed my mind, then.
I cashes in and resign the job
of emperor right this minute.
Well, blimey you're a
cool bird and no mistake.
No use fussing.
When I know the
game's up, I kisses it
goodbye without no long wait.
They's all run off to
the hills, ain't they?
Yes.
Lem was taking 'em,
every man jack of 'em.
Then the revolution
is at the post.
And the emperor better get his
feet smoking up that trail.
Going to look for
your horse, ain't you?
Well, you won't find it.
They steals the
horses first thing.
Well, then I hoofs it.
Feet, do your duty.
3:30.
Sundown's at 6:30 or thereabout.
Ho, I got plenty of
time, make it easy.
Yeah, well don't you
be so blasted sure.
You'll have to hustle to get
to to that port in 12 hours,
even if you knew the trails
like bloomin' native.
Looka here, white man, did you
think I's a natural born fool?
Why, I's gone out in that
forest so many times,
pretending to hunt, I know's
it high and low like a book.
I could find them trails
with my eyes shut.
And I got tin grub hid there
under a big white stone
where I can find it.
Oh, I'll be at the edge of the
forest by the time dark comes.
Once in them woods, them
niggers will never find me.
Dawn tomorrow I reaches
the coast and boards
that French gun boat.
I got to laugh at these fool
black trash around here.
It's so easy.
Supposing something happens
and they does nab you?
I's got five lead bullets
in this gun, good enough
for common bush niggers.
And after that, I's got
this silver bullet left
to cheat 'em outta getting me.
I tells 'em when the time
comes, I kills myself with it.
That's because I'm the
only man in the world
big enough to get me.
Then you had silver bullet made?
Honest?
Oh, I sure did.
Here she be.
Five lead bullets and
a silver baby at last.
Don't she shine pretty?
Let me see.
Keep your hands where
they belong, white man.
Blimey, you'd think
I was a blasted thief.
No, it ain't that.
I know you're scared
to steal from me.
I ain't allowing nobody
to touch this baby.
She's my rabbit's foot.
A sort of charm, eh?
Blimey, you'll need all your
bloomin' charms before long,
so help me.
What's that drumbeating for?
For you!
The blacks is having a
war dance in the hills,
working up their courage
for they start after you.
Let them.
They'll sure need it.
They're making all sorts
of devil spells and charms
against your silver bullet.
Takes more than that
to scare this chicken.
Tonight, when it's
pitch black in the forest,
they'll be sending
their pet devils
and ghosts hounding after you.
You'll find your bloomin'
hair will be standing
on end tomorrow morning.
It's a mighty queer place, that
forest is, even in daylight.
You don't know what
might happen there.
It's that rotten still.
Always sends the cold shivers
down my back the minute
I gets in it.
Go along, white man.
You ain't talking to this baby.
What ghosts and
got to do with me?
Well, don't you know I was
a member in good standing
of the Baptist church?
Let 'em try their
heathen tricks.
And the Baptist church
done protect me.
Land 'em all in hell.
Yeah, you ain't paid
much heed to your Baptist
church down here, taking up with
them bloomin' witch doctors.
Oh, sure, I pretend.
It don't get me nothing
to do missionary work
for the Baptist church.
I's after the coin.
And I lays my religion on
the shelf for the time being.
But I ain't got
the time to waste
no more fool talk with you.
I'm going away this second.
So long, white man.
I'll see you in jail
sometime, maybe.
Not me, you won't.
Here, you ain't going
out this way, are you?
You think I'd sneak out the
back door like a common nigger?
I's emperor yet, ain't I?
And the Emperor Jones
leaves the way he come.
And that black trash
don't dare stop him.
Not yet, leastways.
Listen to that roll
call, will you?
Must be a mighty big
drum carry that far.
Well, if they ain't no whole
brass band to see me off,
I sure got the drum part of it.
So long, white man.
Give my regards to
any ghosts you meet.
Here I is.
In the nick of time, too.
Sure, I's
tuckered out, sure enough.
Whew.
That soft emperor job
sure ain't no training
for a long hike over that
plain in the broiling sun.
Bush niggers.
A wonder they wouldn't get
sick of beating that drum.
Sound louder, seem like.
When did they start in after me?
Oh, sure, they miles
and miles behind.
What you getting fidgety about?
You know what?
Your belly's empty.
That's what's the
matter with you.
Nothing but wind
on your stomach.
Course you feels diggety.
Well, we eats
right here and now.
White stone, white stone.
Where is you?
Ah, here you is.
I know this was the right place.
Box of grub, come to me.
Ain't here.
Has I lost the place?
There's another stone.
Yes, that's it.
Ain't here, neither.
Grub, where is you?
You ain't here.
Has I got to go hungry
in them woods all night?
Can't tell nothing
from them trees.
Nothing around here look
like I ever seen it before.
I done lost the
place sure enough.
Mighty queer.
Woods, is you trying to
put something over on me?
Who that? Who that?
What is you?
Get away from me before
I... They're gone.
Yeah, that shot fix 'em.
Oh, it was only a little animal.
Little wild pigs, I reckon.
They maybe rooted out
your grub and eat it.
Sure, you fool nigger.
What you think they is, hants?
You give the game away
when you fired that shot.
Them niggers'll hear
that for certain.
Get in, nigger.
What you scared at?
Ain't nothing there
but the trees.
Get in there.
The moon's rising.
Did you hear that, nigger?
Get more light from this out,
and you sees where you's going.
Cheer up.
From now on you has a snap.
Whew.
It's warm.
And that's a fact.
How long I been making
tracks in these here woods?
Feel like forever.
This am a long night
for you, your majesty.
Majesty.
There ain't much majesty
about this baby now.
Never mind.
It's all a part of the game.
This night come to an
end like everything else.
You gets there safe and has
that bank roll in your hands,
then you laughs at all this.
What you singing
for, you poor nigger?
Want all the world to hear you?
Hear that old drum.
Sure gets nearer from the sound.
They're packing
it along with 'em.
Time for me to move.
What's the little queer,
clickety sound I hear?
Sound like... sound... it
sounds like some nigger
were shootin' crap.
Time I beats it quick
when I get them notes.
Who there?
Who that?
Is that you, Jeff?
Jeff, I'm sure mighty
glad to see you.
But they told me you done died
from that cut I gives you.
How you come to be here, nigger?
Ain't you going to look up?
Can't you speak to me?
Is you... is you a hant?
Nigger.
I killed you dead once.
Has I got to kill you again?
You take it then.
He's gone, anyway,
hant or no hant.
That shot fixed him.
It's getting nearer.
He's coming fast, and here
I is, shooting shots to let
him know just where I is.
Glory.
I's got to run.
I'm melting with
heat from running
and running and running.
Damn, this here coat
like a straightjacket.
That's better.
Now I can breathe.
I gets rid of them frippity
emperor's trappings
and I travels lighter.
How'd this road ever get here?
I never remember
seein' it before.
These woods are sure full of
the queerest things at night.
Lord God, don't let me
see no more of them hants.
Oh, sure.
That was all in your head.
Wasn't nothing there.
Wasn't no Jeff.
You know what?
You just get seeing them things
because your belly's empty,
and you're sick
with hunger inside.
Bless God I don't see no
more whatever they is.
Mercy, Lord, mercy.
Yes, sir.
I's coming.
You white devil.
I'll gets even with
you yet sometime.
Where's my hammer?
Give me my hammer and
I splits his head.
Give me a hammer, will ya?
Give me a hammer.
I kills you, you
white devil, if it's
the last thing I ever does.
Ghost and devil,
I kills you again!
Oh, Lord, what I
going to do now?
Ain't got no bullets left.
Only the silver one.
What is this place?
Seem like I... seem like
I been here before.
What is I doin'?
Seem like... seem like
I know that stone
and them trees and the river.
I remember... seem like
I been here before.
Oh, oh, glory, I'm
scared of this place.
Him dead.
Lord, I done wrong.
I knows it.
Oh Lord.
Down here where these
fool bush niggers
raised me up into the
seat of the mighty,
I steals all I could grab.
Lord, I done wrong.
I knows it, I's sorry.
Forgive me, Lord.
Forgive this poor sinner.
Oh, Lord, you done
protect this sinner.
You done saved
this sinner, Lord.
I done repent.
Oh, Lord, I done repent.
And I's coming through, Lord.
Oh, Lord, no.
Yes, I...
Have mercy, Lord.
Mercy.
My Lord, hear my prayers!
Oh!
The silver bullet!
You don't gets me yet!
I bet he's miles away way by
now and safe at the coast.
I told you you'd
lose him, didn't I?
Beating your silly drum and
casting your stinking spells.
Blimey, what a pack.
We'll catch him.
You see.
Why don't you go in the
woods and hunt after him?
What's the good in waiting?
We catch him.
Well, you ain't thinking
that's him, I hopes.
That's him.
My men got silver
bullet, kill him sure.
They got a silver bullet?
Lead bullet no kill him.
Him got strong charm.
I cook money, make
silver bullet.
Make strong charm, too.
Ahh.
Well, they did for you
right enough, Jonesy, me lad.
Dead as a herring.
Where's all your
high and mighty airs
now, your bloomin' majesty?
Silver bullets.
Blimey.
Anyhow, you died in
the height of style.
Subtitles Diego Moraes(oakislandtk)
www.opensubtitles.org